ladies do you have a screenwriting
routine do we have a screenwriting
routine we have a bit of a screenwriting
routine we do I guess what yeah uh I
come over to Janice's after work we she
cooks dinner create dinner we talk about
right now well right now we're in kind
of a rewrite phase so we're in a place
where we conceptualizing some of the
relationships so we'll kind of have
those kinds of discussions over dinner
and then we'll go downstairs and we'll
look at the board and that's more of a
plotting kind of figuring out how these
new relationships are going to fit into
our new plot yeah so and it usually
always involves chocolate in some kind
of way that's our muse so yeah well
Janice I think you said previously that
you write at night like late at night
and barrington you're a morning person
right we do we do both right I think I
feel more inspired when the world is
quiet and the phones aren't ringing and
Twitter's not going off or the cell
phone isn't going off and I can kind of
let my imagination just run where it
wants to go because there's nothing
distracting and and I feel like even in
the work that I do as a journalist
that's when I get my inspiration I'm a
little bit more relaxed and I'm not I'm
actually not as self-conscious at night
as I am in the day something about the
lights being on and the light being up
makes me a little more this has to be
this way and I think I can play in my
mind at night better now I have a
follow-up question to that because I I
know that Janice is somebody who will
say I'm gonna go to bed I'm going to set
my alarm for like 2 or 3 a.m. and I'm
going to get up and I'm going to work so
when you say you work better at night is
it you stay awake all through the day
and then at night you find that place or
are you talking about when you've gotten
up
basically still in the middle of the
night yeah when I've gotten up in the
non like I'll set my alarm for like two
or three o'clock and I'll get up and
usually like I'll have a shower so I'm
feeling kind of relaxed and comfortable
and I think when the shower starts well
I work well by water or with water I get
inspired because I'm not really thinking
about what I'm supposed to be writing
but the characters start coming alive to
me and and then because I do keep a pad
in my bathroom techniques are right and
and then I go downstairs or go in my
bedroom or stay in my bedroom and just
kind of write things out and kind of
freehand things so yeah I think being in
an atmosphere where I don't feel like I
have to write right at a desk or a
computer I free write a lot by hand so
and then I take that and then put it on
the computer so yeah so that way we're
actually pretty similar because it's
almost like you're a morning writer it's
just because because I'm the same way I
get up in the morning and although I
don't shower or do anything I can't I of
the Edith Wharton School where I just
kind of open might like stay in bed open
my laptop and then just start working
because the minute I go outside and see
like the sink is full of dishes I'm like
maybe I'll do a few dishes or something
like that but if you just like kind of
stay in squalor ensconced in your bed
you can get a fair amount done before
you have to really face the world so
that's that's good but for me that's you
know because I think we we both tend to
have a few projects going on at once so
usually it's not this project that is
the morning hours project that's kind of
more although will be again when we get
into the writing out of the discussion
phase and into the writing phase just
have curiosity where I have you born at
in the middle of the night or in the
early morning I know
they say people do their best maybe that
theory doesn't work here I was born in
the afternoon okay all right whether you
have a border like 821 p.m. but I could
be no cut up but that's a turd in Jordan
area yeah I'm fine with writing at night
do you almost feel like there's a
pressure to be so perfect that in at
night time you can kind of let it go I
think that's really interesting yeah I
think for me because daytime is business
time that's when the journalism work
gets done that's when the emails get
taken care of that's when the phones are
on that's when I'm communicating with
people and since I live alone it's very
easy to for me to use the night as my
plate my personal playtime and so it's
the time when after dinner is over and I
live in a community and so nobody else
is awake you know even the world is
quiet you know there's nothing going I
live next to a park so nobody's playing
in the park there's nobody on the street
there are no cars it's just a very calm
serene peaceful time and so I get to you
know do you know it sounds a little
wicked actually but it's data it's like
it's like that's when I get so you know
I'm kind of a vampire in that way that I
get to you know do my thing and I really
get to connect with my either higher
power or muse or my other voice and and
really exercise at at nighttime so but
that you know that that's when I when I
can feel you know even if I'm listening
to music that's when I can hear the
music and it innit you know music became
a big part of this of our screenplay
because I am so very connected to music
but I could hear music in a different
way than I at night then I can during my
daytime like something about even a
string instrument coming out or or the
lyric
on a particular word in a song resonates
with me in a different way and so
through the writing process on those
times when I was alone and rewriting
without barrington I listened to music a
lot and I have certain soundtracks for
each character that really helped
inspire kind of the mood that I was
feeling or the the flow that I was
taking when I was prewriting alone
barrington for you
is there something about the structure
of the morning and knowing that I think
you said you had to be at work or out
the door by noon or something right yeah
I work 12 to 5 so we don't know that
yeah it's like it's good so you know put
with commutes and stuff so I'm fine out
at 11:25 I'll be right on time I'm
usually out of 11:27 and hum and then
you missed the Train and so lateness has
a whole different kind of trajectory
when when you're dealing with some some
form of public transportation because
like two minutes late becomes the next
train which is ten minutes late or
twelve minutes late but anyway yeah I'm
somebody who I'm pretty happy when I'm
writing the mornings good you wake up
you do have less things going on in the
morning nighttime I I used to really be
able to get into a place at night but I
think it's mostly worrying about getting
up in the morning that keeps me from
writing late into the night as much as I
used to
more and more I think I'm getting into a
place where I you know with practice you
get to a place where you can just kind
of dive in from almost anywhere I mean I
can pretty much write on the train if I
can get a seat potential I can't write
when I'm driving so that's annoying but
I can kind of curl up anywhere and get a
few words I can't write and drive I know
you know it's funny because I do know
like I'll have like a pad in the
passenger side and like I keep a pen
I can't pads and pens like hidden all
over the house and anywhere and there
are times when like something will hit
me and I'm just like okay I can read it
but sighs I can't but yeah I do I do
find that I I think it's because I Drive
alone a lot you know I'm alone a lot I'm
a single person and so and so I can
choose when to engage with others and so
I think in my alone time is when you
know even if there's like a particular
NPR story that had like we're working on
a story that has some contact sub
subtext to Los Angeles and housing and
so there was a story on and I was like
huh I need to write that down so that I
can tell Barrington that we you know we
heard this you know story so it's it's
really interesting you know just
thinking about it now how connected I am
to a pen and a piece of paper at all
times but I don't write in cafes well I
tried that it's too distracting for me
yeah that's not my favorite yeah either
I mostly those are those are like token
writing sessions where a friend asks you
they're like oh you want to go write at
the you know well vlog you're like oh
I'd like to catch up with that friend
you don't actually think I have it if
you have a real deadline you're like no
yeah the only time I did do a cafe
writing was when I was really trying to
eavesdrop on certain kinds of
conversations been wanting to get a flow
in a rhythm for like a particular voice
that was the only time but it wasn't you
know it was there I was there snooping I
was eavesdropping I was you know I
wanted to hear something different than
I would hear in my own voice and so but
that's when cafe writing or other kinds
of out but usually I'm in my my home
office or somewhere around my house how
long have the two of you been writing
partners Barrington and I have been
writing together
I would say we're not a traditional
writing partnership we are Co writers on
a particular
screenplay and so we've been doing that
now for three years three years yeah
yeah number of 2013 2013 yeah happy
Anniversary thank you so it was about
yeah was about June was it yeah about
June when we when we connected so it
seems like the two of you are similar
but very different in certain styles of
writing do you think you could partner
up with someone that was just like you
that's a good question I don't know I've
had very few partnerships in my career
as I mentioned I'm a journalist by trade
and so usually I work by myself mostly
and this is actually my first feature
film screenplay so it's been an
interesting journey just kind of feeding
off of each other
I think our differences do help us it's
opened me up certainly to ideas and
concepts in a world that I may not have
considered so I think there is benefit
especially for what we're doing there is
benefit and the differences there is
we're writing an interracial
intercultural cross face guide to love
story and so our difference is you know
from where we both racially where we
come from adds to that it really does
you know we don't often agree on
everything you know we have moments
where it's like no no no this is debate
supposed to be that's how it's going to
be but then you know you back up and you
think okay well this is something valid
and maybe I need to consider it and so
you know I take it you know some time
and like okay remember that thing you
were talking about let's revisit that so
so I think the difference is to do add
to hopefully a deeper complexity of what
what we're trying to do yeah I don't
know I think for me I writing with
somebody who's just like like
writing with a clone has always been a
dream right because somebody can be
somebody's thinking exactly like you're
thinking and but you can still be doing
one thing while work is happening and
especially if you're somebody who kind
of always a little bit time-poor in the
various resources I kind of never have
time to worry about affected I'm
probably money poor because I'm so time
for but but well it's like oh where am I
going to put these hours so this idea of
you know putting something up there and
having somebody really understand what
you're where you're coming from is this
kind of fantasy but how well would it
work really I mean for something like
this it's like I know that we have a
person we have a Persian wedding scene
in our script Janice got in the car and
drove to San Diego and went to a Persian
wedding show for an entire day and came
back at with tons of you know material
and vocabulary words and business cards
and my quote neither me nor my clone
would drive to San Diego and go to the
to the Persian wedding show like we
would both be kind of introverted you
know people like like I am so in that
way like this has been super you know
it's very complimentary would it be the
best thing for every script maybe not
every script but but for just for this
script I think it works and you know and
you know I talk about it a lot I love
the work that Barrington does do and and
I do enjoy the producing side of things
so it's like I whatever she wants to to
do producing I can produce it I may not
write with her but I believe in the kind
of work that she does the kinds of
characters that she puts out and so if
that was something that those are ways
that I would love to try to work with
her some more but you know like my next
script is completely different with you
know it's a musical and it's
religious-based and it takes a different
kind of a different look and a different
exploration that I don't even think
Barrington would have an interest in so
so interesting coming to see it and I'm
already interested in like seeing who
maybe you partner up with because I mean
there's got to be so many interesting
people in the world who are involved
with what that kind of thing yeah I
think with any partnership it's it's
always about you know a marriage a
writing partnership anything it's about
kind of looking and seeing what you have
and how those pieces fit together and I
feel like we've managed to come up with
a pretty good jigsaw cut yeah we're here
because we just had there was just a
best friends day or whatever it was and
and you know I have a lot of personal
best friends who I grew up with but then
I realized you know Barrington's my best
friend writing friend you know I don't
have a relationship with relationship
with another writer in the way that I
have was Barrington
I mean we've we've had we've now
traveled together a couple of times we
spend a lot of time together here and
you know she has keys to my home and she
comes in just like I'm home
so we're kind of you know you know a
good little good little marriage as she
was saying so so she is someone who I
whose work I value whose opinions matter
to me and the relationship is important
even beyond the writing of it so so I
think that's what makes me really want
to continue to work with her in some
kind of way it may not be a writing kind
of way but definitely she stuck with me
I think one thing that's nice about a
partnership that works is when you
present an idea and you feel safe
telling the other person that I get even
if they don't like it so what works best
for the two of you is it the blunt you
know what sorry she's not like this
sucks I don't like it I know what could
we see if it works like this over here
how does that work between the two of
you I think we're doing that now you
know there's some there's some sticking
points on something
and we're just like you know she's like
okay I'm gonna leave you to this I'll
come back in a couple of days and let's
talk about it
and so I I do think that you know I'm a
woman with very strong opinions about a
lot of things and there are things that
I feel or into it in a way that maybe
Barrington doesn't so then I take what
she's said and go okay I see where she's
coming from
and I still don't agree or I see where
she's coming from and let's see how this
works and so it has been a I think the
thing that to back up I think the thing
that I've learned about this partnership
and and really try we both want to try
to make the best product that we can and
I think that the the core of it and so
when she says something and I'm like huh
doesn't even make any sense to me but
then I have to I have I have to step
back each sometimes in the moment or
sometimes after and go you know what
that thing you were talking about it
gave us some consideration let's let's
see how this goes and see how this plays
out and so we're going through that now
with a particular scene where we're like
hey why is it seem like this why should
we do it like this I like it this way
she likes it this way and we're just
kind of trying to figure it out
and and I think the thing that wins is
what we both feel makes it the better
story right oh go ahead sorry oh yeah I
think I guess you know to respond to
your question I think I think we're both
we always try to start with a place of
well I don't know how do you you know
how do you think this would work and or
you know what if it was this way and
then and then there's a but there's also
there's kind of a spectrum of that you
know there's the beginning of the
conversation
and then there's like 10 o'clock at
night we're just like ya know filters
off yeah yeah but um but overall I mean
I think I think we we do have a pretty
good rapport where we go back and forth
a little bit and and when when it's
sticky we take a little time we come
back together sometimes we Duke it out
and we haven't had like had to resort to
flipping coins yet so but we haven't I
like the spectrum analogy because it
seems like with any great partnership
you have to be in a place where you're
not afraid of hurting one other's
feelings but you don't do in a way that
really wounds someone I think that's a
real decision-maker with a lot of things
yeah I try I think the thing that that
it comes down to is that that I trust
barrington and I think that's important
I know she when she first came on you
know came on to help me with the outline
the one thing that I found really
revealing about barrington was that she
took care of you know she was thoughtful
about what she wanted to do and about
the characters and and and inquired and
and wanted to know and so it made you
know like this may not have been a
project she was like oh yeah I'm really
going to co-write this with you right
now it was it started off as a I'm a
journalist who wrote a book she had
screenwriting experience and she was
going to help me develop an outline that
looked the way it was supposed to when I
presented it to a production company and
it was through that process where I
think for me it was really I think I can
work with this person are you interested
in working with a novice like me and so
I think Trust was a big just was a big
deal for me and I felt like she was
somebody that I could open up to you and
be comfortable
knowing you know cuz she now knows on my
little ugly secrets and the beautiful
ones and this is really wacky ones and
and I and I feel like I can trust her
with that part of me so I can also trust
her with this this is this thing that
that you know I kind of conceived but
we're birthing it together what you
consider to be the perfect screenplay
and why whether it's your own work in a
recent action first time today ready for
you although you're getting both getting
originally curved you perfect screen but
whether it's someone else's or even a
page out of your own that you're working
on I think for me because this was my
first screenplay one of the things that
I wanted to do is read every screenplay
I could get my little hands on and one
of the actually there's three that I
really kind of gravitated to Dallas
buyers club which I still have yet to
see but I have read it and I've read it
about four times I think it's a
marvelous screenplay and I'm almost
afraid to watch it I know it did well
and I just I it was like a novel it read
almost like a novel and sometimes I'm
afraid to like look at what that you
know because it doesn't match my my
vision I mean and I know it did well at
the Oscars and it was very inspiring for
me because that was a project that took
about 20 years to make but it's just so
well structured it moves so beautifully
it's so visual in its construct I felt
the same way about bridesmaids and then
I went back and read guess who's coming
to dinner the the original screenplay
for guess who's coming to dinner and
that screenplay just the opening is tons
of fun it's just I think there's a line
in there where it says you know this
this black man and this white girl kiss
in the taxi cab and watch the audience
go crazy it was like they were
commenting you know this film was done
in 1967 it was written in 1967 before
the Virginia vs. loving a ruling came
down that allowed interracial couples to
marry in the United States and so this
was still a big deal at the time and so
just reading that first bit of narrative
was it was hilarious
and it's and it's just really well done
from I mean for me there's just so many
the first script I think I ever read was
Alexander Payne's election and he's
somebody who has a lot of voice in his
in his scripts he'll be kind of witty or
you know you and a lot of times he's
adapting as I think almost always he's
adapting from a book and so maybe some
of that is it's coming from that but I
mean I remember thinking oh you have to
have style in the way that that you're
expressing something and that the tone
of your movie can be reflected in the
voice of your screenplay I mean I love
children of men I go back to that a lot
Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind as
a movie and I think I have read this I
have a picture in my in my head of the
screenplay and I'm I'd have to think a
little harder about how that translates
what did I just
I'm not halfway through a beautiful mind
right now and that just really
interesting things too so I don't know
about the perfect screenplay but there's
a lot of great movies out there that had
as screenplays great blueprints on their
own and in their actualization because I
don't know when I I went back to what
like might one of my favorite films of
all times as broadcast news I love that
film and I went back and read the
screenplay and their screenplays very
different is different in a lot of ways
than what was actually shot so it gave
me a different and maybe that's why I
don't want to see that right above like
what if they took this out oh no what if
that's not in there so there were things
in the broadcast news script that
weren't in the film and or things that
were dialogue that was changed and so it
was really interesting because I know
that screenplay I mean I know that film
so well to then go back and watch the
screen to read the screenplay and see
how different it was it was it was
actually very interesting and revealing
but now it's just like home dog why is
it why wasn't that I wasn't that in the
movie so so yeah though yeah that's I
think it's I'm actually I'm teaching a
class at one of the community colleges
this fall and it's going to be my first
experience teaching a screenwriting
class and we're going to be working with
short films but the book that I've
selected specifically because they have
the scripts for the short films in the
book but they are not transcriptions of
the movies that got made because I think
it's it's so important to realize that
whatever it is that you're making is
only a part of the whole that like that
as much as this is a collaborative
process that when we get to the next
stage it's going to be another
collaborative process and then it's
going to become something else so I
think it is interesting and sometimes
you do look back and like something got
lost and then sometimes it just
transcends what was there so
well speaking of women that have
opinions I just began reading the
biography of Susan Sontag
and she talks about her upbringing in
the first chapter or the book does so
it's not an autobiography but and I know
this is this is not a new question but
do you think a good writer starts from
strained beginnings strained beginnings
and and did she put that that phrase in
the context a little bit well there's a
quote as it opens up the book and she
said this in 1987 the distance from my
origins is exactly what I like there was
nothing I could return to mmm so without
going too much in her own personal story
even though she grew up fairly well-off
it wasn't a happy beginning and she
never really felt part of where she came
from she always wanted to get out even
was a comfortable middle-class
upbringing that's interesting right okay
so there sorry the question again was do
I think do we think what comes from
reading an excellent writer somebody who
is really able to go there deep into the
dark places of the human mind and up
into the the high manic points part do
you think it has to come from your doing
like two artists have to suffer yeah and
a cliche question yeah elmo's what truth
ya know I mean because you know having
suffered a little myself every once in a
while like suffering is about compassion
and it's about empathy and it's about
like if you strange beginnings or
certain kinds of suffering any like
strips it kind of strips away a lot of
all but the mem on my facebook this
morning with JK Rowling who was talking
about when she hit rock bottom and she
wasn't homeless but she was like next
best thing to homeless that you could be
in Britain and she's like everything
else is gone and this is all
it's left and and so it's it's easier at
that point to kind of look and say what
are the important things what are the
essential things that you want to convey
what is most important to you both in
your life like what do you want to do
but I think also in your writing I don't
think it hurts sure yeah I'm sure that
there's some some people out there
who've had really pleasant lives and are
also awesome writers but I think it's I
think as much as we can you know as we
can empathize and as much as suffering
gives us a little nudge toward that it's
helpful yeah I think you know I had a
lovely childhood I grew up middle-class
I grew up in Los Angeles but at a
certain point I had you know challenges
with my father and you know I'm divorced
and you know I have health issues and
there are certain things that that when
I think about where I am now you know in
my late 40s moving into my 50s that I
can draw from and that I can use and
mine and we were recently in Switzerland
workshopping our screenplay and we had
an opportunity to work with an actress
and really go deep and and I realized
there were things that I was not opening
myself up to as a writer that could feed
the story in a way that you know I
wanted to be you know I wanted to keep
that side separate and when we really
opened ourselves up to this hurt and
this loss
this painting we're like oh that could
be really good and I think because my
background is in journalism I'm
reflecting on other people's lives and
sharing other people's stories and I'm
always focusing that way focusing
outward and this is really forced to me
to focus inward on what really what
really hurts and what really and where
my courage has to come from and in turn
where this character's courage and her
truth has to come from so um you know
but I'm not a you know I'm not a drinker
I'm not a smoker I don't do drugs you
know I don't have those kinds of
proclivity but you know which a lot of
writers tend to have but I do feel like
my own personal journey has been
important in my writing and whether it's
as difficult as someone else's maybe not
but it had its own share of challenges
and so I use that for what I need for
this yeah we hear a lot about people
that have a glass of wine or something
else stronger than coffee you know what
do you think about that because I think
for some people and they say all great
rock songs have been written but you
know and there's there's I think two
schools of thought but then you also
hear the stories about you know Stephen
King and on writing he talks about how
his career got to a certain point and he
was using and he had to stop mm-hmm
it wasn't you know it's actually funny
because when I first started working on
this project a girlfriend of mine who's
a writer she's like you need to get out
of yourself drink a glass of wine and
you know two glasses check the whole
bottle and I thought I don't even know
how to start with that but you know I
get wine for gifts because I'm not a
drinker and so I don't even know what I
really would like and I did I drank like
Elmo
a bottle of wine and I went to sleep so
it didn't serve me you know like I got
really energetic and cleaned the house
and then at a certain point it just it
didn't because she her thing was that it
relaxes you it allows you to to let go
but I find when I do my early morning
writing you know or late night writing
at 3:00 and 4:00 a.m. that gives me that
that feeds me as much as any other
stimulant or depressant or anything else
so I just I just try to I just try to go
inside myself and I think because I free
right it allows me to not criticize
myself because my free writing is just
my just my thoughts and and how I'm
feeling and things like that when I go
to the computer that's when the rubber
meets the road this is how this has to
be perfect this has to be good but if
they're you know but I can see things
and my free writing that I'm thinking
because even when we were at the
workshop in Switzerland we had this
challenge where we had to write a scene
a new scene for our screenplay specific
to this character and her mother who had
died and it was Mother's Day and it was
the first time in my 48 years on this
planet that I had not been with my
mother on Mother's Day my mother's still
alive but I wasn't with her and I
emailed her in Worcester happy Mother's
Day and I felt this disconnect for the
first time like my mother's not here and
I'm not celebrating with her and for
women who are for people who have lost
their parent I'm blessed to still have
both of mine but you know like Father's
Day came my dad and my mother were on
their 50th wedding anniversary you know
trip I didn't spend Mother's Day or
Father's Day this year with either of my
parents and it was just like this weird
disconnect so I tap into that
I tap into that feeling of you know
while I was sitting in Switzerland I was
like talking to my mother like sharing
things with her about what I was doing
on that day and it turned out to be a
really nice scene that we acted out
during our workshop and but it would
have never come that way and I don't
know if drugs would have helped thing
like that
but it just comes from my let it comes
from my letting go
my personal letting go so yeah yeah yeah
when you think about drugs and writing
or then there's a couple ways that you
you tend to think okay how can it be
helping and one is is it stimulating
creativity and the other is is it
working by kind of vanquishing
inhibitions and your inner critic and
I'm not I'm also someone for because of
certain health reasons I quit drinking
at a certain point and so I don't I
don't really indulge I had a and I also
had a roommate back in the day and he I
mean he always wrote his songs smoking
pot they were pretty good songs would
they have been better songs I don't know
but so anyway inhibition or creativity
so if we assume that your creativity is
there and and the only thing that's
blocking it is your inhibitions then I
think it's about generating about having
a practice of being able to kind of dive
into that place and actors have to do it
I recently took an improv class I think
every time I do something like that
every time I do things that that kind of
combat my natural inhibitions it's
that's good for me and I you know I feel
like I'm not bad at it on the page but
then I go out into the world and I'll
you know and I see people who are great
at it at really like tossing things off
in you know the the improv class was was
great
was a stolen workshop so not like Second
City I'm being funny but more like I'm
being present I'm being in the moment
I'm imagining myself fully in this place
and I'm reacting in real-time
and and that for me is often the
reacting in real-time is not a strong
suit of mine I'm a delayed reactor so
all of that I feel like in terms of my
life as as an artist and a storyteller
it's something where I really do try to
keep finding opportunities to work with
that so that I can I can reach that
place because I think we do I think I
think everything is tempting if you're
you know be it you know various
substances or practices or what have you
if you you want to kind of get to a
deeper level and you know be better than
what you are so I understand that the
two of you were selected to be part of
some type of group of esteemed
screenwriters to go to a castle and
right yes and not to self deprecated I
don't know if it's a Steve but we were
super lucky they picked it the
Association is called dream ago and they
run a workshop called penny película
which is pen and film in French and and
they do cut of a writer's lab so maybe
and set up a little different but a
little bit the same as if you've heard
of the Sundance screenwriting lab so the
way they organized it was that they
brought in five or six professional
consultants who are have you know
writers in their own right or who have
been executives who work with with
screenwriters professionally and then
they ten ten teams of participants we
there were two two or three sets there
was a 3-cent regime yes we were one of
them and we were one and so you would
read everybody's script from you know
who was going and
so you had a set of you would meet with
each of the professional consultants and
then you would also meet with all the
other screenwriters individually and
kind of exchange notes so we ended up
with 14 seconds which I understand you
wrote a blog post ah a little bit of
research and research yet two-headed
monster about notes which I find
interesting how was that to receive
notes as a group versus maybe the usual
way of just individually well I yeah I
think that you know like for me since
this was my first time doing a workshop
of this nature I mean I went back to
school and got an advanced degree and so
we had workshop I had done workshops
with my work there but this was a lot of
first of all it was an international
group of people so there were people
from Cuba and from Switzerland and from
France and we were the only u.s. script
that was accepted into the program which
I'm actually quite proud of and the only
English language script that was chosen
so so we had it you know we had
translators and so there was you know
there were moments where we would you
know and barrington studied very
vigorously her Spanish I have some
Spanish background but neither of us are
fluent and so it was kind of trying to
make sure did we understand the
translation so did we understand the
context in you know so like my my
questions were always kind of you know
if there was a question about a note
then you know I wanted to know
specifically like where that came from
whether it be like a man that was
talking to us from Cuba who had a
different you know understanding of this
particular cultural world than than we
did and so you know it was it was
wonderful and exhausting and lots of
notes and so like that you know that's
what we you know we're really fishing
through and kind of sorting out like
there are certain through lines
thankfully that you know when people
were talking about deeper more complex
or those kinds of things that is easy to
understand and ride but then when
someone says oh this scene should
definitely not be there and someone else
says that scene is the best scene in the
whole film and you're like okay this is
so so it's just about for me at least
and I was talking to Barrington about
this this morning one of the things that
I had to do is like take in the context
all the notes and all the comments and
all the everything and then go back
inside and go what am I really trying to
say here and what fits with what we're
trying to say and what helps strengthen
what we're trying to say because there
there is so much like oh that's a great
idea or I never thought about that or
saying they want us to lose that whole
day that was my favorite part and so it
really is about remembering what the
story is you want to try to tell or at
least that that's kind of how I'm going
at it and what makes sense to help
propel that to a better place and so you
know it was a manic week of screenings
and writing and listening to criticism
and eating which you know we have no
problem with but it's intense it's very
very intense and so for me you know
between the jetlag and a penci one's
body just trying to be present trying to
understand and trying to stay awake and
you know really fully take things in
because you know sleep deprivation fits
into all that stuff but it was the most
exciting thing because in you know in
those moments
in those opportunities you know getting
to sit at a bench that had a heartbeat
can't be different spiration there
wasn't there was a patch outside outside
the castle so it was kind of like an art
installation art installation and so
like you you if you sat on it you it
would kind of start it was the health it
pulsates I thought you know it was a
metaphor
no it was an actual physical actual
physical heart beating or beating bench
and so I and that's kind of and it was
20 because that's where I sat when I was
writing my note about this character and
her mother who was deceased being
separated from my mother who was in Los
Angeles and I was in Switzerland not
early but on Mother's Day and there's
this pulsating around me and inside of
me and so it it was you know and it was
so funny because but you know and I've
told this story before you know some of
the consultants I just connected with
them you know like some of them I just
genuinely connected with them as people
and you know one of the the consultants
there was a really stressful evening one
evening and I was just like you know and
Barrington was just like you know she
lets it out in one way and I'm just like
and to his credit he took me out to the
to the outside and he's like just scream
your head off just just he's like
because it will make you sick he's like
you can't keep us so I find myself now
like when things really stress me out to
just find ways to let it go even if I
just go to the beach and just go there's
a new movement that does that really
like primal screaming yeah so you know
so I got more out of that than just the
writing I think that was really
important to me you know it feeds what
I'm doing
a writer but there was so much more and
even when that same consultant and I
were talking he's like could this be
done in Los Angeles and I was like nope
you could I don't think you could do the
same
although the lab that that experience
and gets that because we were in a small
town it was surrounded by vineyards it's
a very different kind of experience like
Patong shut down on Sundays I haven't
met that since my you know young days in
the cells like in you know and now
everything's open and you know like
where my mother's from everything's open
on Sunday but that place shut down
except for the cinema and one grocery
store was open to like two or three or
something like that but it you know like
everything just kind of got quiet and
some of the rest some of the pubs and
restaurants stayed open but it was just
kind of like Surrey it was like this is
Sunday yeah and I haven't met that in a
while just like wow so there were other
experiences that went along with that
that to me were we're inspiring and and
I think it it did bring Barrington and I
closer together I think because we had
even though we had travel together
before this is the first time we'd been
on a plane together and traveled a lot
for 14 hours together and we were
working together we were living in the
same space before we had we had gone to
Austin for a film festival but she came
after I did we were staying in separate
venues and so we would just kind of meet
up like and then we dined together you
know like we had to eat you know we we
would often eat together because
sometimes we were the only English
speakers at the table and other people
will be talking in their own language so
so it was one of those things where you
know like I learned a lot more about she
and her husband and how they got to get
like I've known her for three years I
didn't know how that you know like that
how that story came about and it had an
impact on you know when they gave notes
she
was like yeah well you know when when my
husband and I were together this was hot
and I was like oh we can do that yeah I
was like it was this a really great
sharing of ideas and time and personal
space because like I said I live alone
so you know like I was with Barrington
for a whole week and you know and you
know she's like do I snore and you know
or you know in bathrooms that you know
women in bathroom space is so so you
know so those things really did kind of
enhance the partnership in my life
estimation even including the writing
yeah so you'd asked about just the the
note getting process oh my gosh getting
notice I know it all on that tangent you
set that up okay but yeah so I guess two
things you know Janice talked about it a
little bit you know one is there's the
there's the actual moment of getting you
know getting the notes and how you
respond to notes and and she's somebody
who definitely like likes to kind of
follow up and ask questions and
investigate I'm a journalist I know and
I kind of come from this this you know
writers with in in writing parlance
they're like you're in the booth and you
don't really get to respond you don't
respond to notes when like for a certain
point like so there's there's a theory
of getting notes that when somebody's
giving you notes that that you kind of
try to stay very neutral because any
reactions that you give to them is then
going to provoke them to change the kind
of response that they're giving to you
because we have this humanity where we
don't want to hurt people's feelings and
we want you know people to like us and
and things like that so so you kind of
so I'm kind of like okay you know so my
just my natural I don't know if it's
natural but my over the years kind of
bond side
together shape of things is that you
know I just I'm like okay maybe I don't
entirely understand that note in the
moment but I'm just going to like listen
to all the notes and then that's today
me and then tomorrow me is going to go
figure it out so that's the ideal right
but then in practice of course it's
emotionally confronting all the time and
and for your like if you're just by
yourself and you're getting notes then
you you know you're all you're going to
be thinking oh what are they talking
about can I fix this and and where did
this go wrong and data someone you have
two people you have two people who were
responsible for the writing you have two
people who are thinking those things you
have two people who are who are kind of
thinking oh yeah that is a flaw and I
thought it was a flaw when we did it but
this other person didn't think it was a
flaw and so you know it's a it does you
know it does bring you closer because
you have to work through all of that and
and say okay now we're going to go back
to the drawing board and and then later
on there's interpretation of those notes
well I don't know if I really meant that
note and like I don't
was this the it was this the important
part or was this the important part so
it's it's just another I mean it's
collaboration right but it's it's it's
adding a layer of interpretation and
judgment to everything that you do but
it's also kind of comforting in a way
because you have this person who's with
you when you're getting these getting
these notes and you know that this
person is supporting you and if you're
going someplace kind of emotional if you
feel safe with that person that's a you
know so it works both ways yeah it's
just actually handwritten notes type
notes almost all verbal all Gabel yeah
yeah so you're sitting there like yeah
sitting across the table from someone
there you know kind of maybe they're
referring to notes but they're giving
them to you person to person
yeah so how many writers were there
altogether not not the actual note
givers but the actual writers be
encrypted so 13 12 to 13 there was one
team who was I was a husband-wife team
and she was there part-time because they
just had a baby together so she was
there full-time and then there was
another writing team Jack and right yeah
so 10 scripts and Jacques a general yes
Jerome works yeah we're so literally yes
so I guess that makes 10 12 30 30 yeah
so us the other writers that were there
for each other none of the writers that
were there at this castle being 14
what did you observe about their
temperament and how they worked what
were the similarities that you saw like
oh I do that - isn't that funny that's
kind of like writers temperament and
then there's other things that you maybe
didn't identify with how are you so
similar yeah well I thought it was it's
a very interesting group because because
a few of them have an acting background
and when you come to writing from acting
I think you're coming from a little bit
of a different place so those people I
thought I could feel being you know
they're a little more extroverted and
they're they're kind of tend to be I
think they're approaching things a
little more emotionally from care you
know from character and then quite a few
of them were also filmmakers in their
own right like a lot of them were
working on documentaries were directors
and so I was I was really impressed
just with the it kind of a compartment
the confidence that that people really
seemed to have it's interesting also
confidence in terms of how they
presented their work like they weren't
afraid to show it
ah
I think I'm kind of thinking of Julie
just like just calm and they've been
around the block a few times we're
working in kind of an independent film
arena with this film so I think here
it's very hard because you're really at
the bottom of the barrel people kind of
look at their like although the
writing's good but who's going to apply
this who's going to watch this who's
going to distribute this and you get to
Europe where where a lot of you know a
lot of issue related films a lot of
documentaries they're funded by the
places that they come from the state
funds you if you live in Colombia every
like while we were there we were kind of
putting together our our application
packet for Sundance labs but the other
people who were there we're putting
together their stuff for the government
funding from Colombia so you you know
it's like I think here you spend I don't
I could be totally wrong I feel like I'm
somebody who spent a fair amount of time
studying a fair amount of time aspiring
and until somebody really takes
something and says I'm going to pay you
for your time I love what you're doing
we're going to make this you're still
you're still kind of reaching for that
and so you're working in working with
people who are already there they're
like oh yeah I've been shooting this
documentary for seven years and I know
where the funding is for the post and
we're going to you know put it together
and then they're going to show it
somewhere it's kind of like maybe it's
that I'm like oh they feel more grown-up
than me right okay I'm not that they're
worth more or even working harder or
even you know that we aren't kind of
comparable in our knowledge about things
but there was you know there was just
kind of like a calmness sometimes and
then sometimes it's also like being at
summer camp look so by the end of the
week nerves are frayed everybody's like
on their 12th a set of notes they're
like yes yeah
you've told me you know 12 other people
have told me that this flaw exists and
now you're telling me again and then
people get a little snappy sure you know
yeah yes kind of like the real world
screen yeah they're like you know why
are you smoking on the porch why are you
on the porch if you don't want to be
near the smoke going to like those shows
like the real world starts encroaching
ten words every screenwriter should know
and utilize in their script feature
length script ten words they should know
and utilize in the screen in their
script right moving from let's say great
or something simple to something more
like arduous stodgy byzantines
like either certain words I mean this is
just like this sort of strange throwaway
question but sometimes it's important
because it gets people out of the just
the things that they should put words
they should put into their screenplay
yeah something favorite flavorful words
yeah I don't know that I'm going to be
able to do I'm always terrible at you
know like at top ten lists I will I will
say come from a background where where I
try not to use the versions of to be and
these kind of like gerund words like if
you know she is walking you know she
walks to the door you're like what's the
difference but you're kind of looking
for the more visceral words so and and
you are looking for you're looking for
the verbs that that kind of let you not
have to use adverbs so you know you try
and constantly trying to stay away from
those kind of ly adverbs so you know you
don't say she she you could you could
say she she starts walking to the door
confidently or you could say she struts
to the door so you're looking for those
robust kind of muscular words do I have
a list of those words I don't know that
I do but I know that I'm always
searching for them do you yeah I coming
from journalist you know and that's the
way that it it's it's an interesting
question that I strangely can't answer
because there's so many beautiful words
that one could use and and when I think
you know and I can't even
about one from even our script that I
was just like that was the most
marvelous word ever I think that a lot
of what Barrington has said just just
finding ways to utilize the language
that is bright and full and even complex
are great things to do but again one
particular word or a series of words
because they are always dependent on
what you're writing about because I you
know I love the word lied but I don't
ever see that in the show think that's
in our sketch that would never be in our
scripts because that doesn't describe
anyone in our script but I it's a word
that I particularly love because it says
so much and it's such a little word or
petite word so yeah yeah I think that's
that's a hard one I usually can answer
anything yeah that's a stumper I think
about verbs a lot and and maybe because
of the medium I think I try to think
about light I mean it's a it's a
two-dimensional medium and you can't
really smell things and and the dialogue
is there so you can kind of you know we
do this thing where we cap the sounds
you know the car screeches around the
corner to like kind of give you that
that sense but I think also
understanding that there's you know
glistens is you know and glows and yeah
like the light is what you know kind of
watery or you know trying to to get to
transmit the texture of things the sheen
of things is interesting
probably not always applicable depending
on your subject matter but yeah I use my
thesaurus a lot
so it's my favorite book what about
writing prompts what if you're kind of
stuck with something what do you use as
a prompt I know you had talked about
going to a cafe only to eavesdrop and
get ideas which sounds great but I know
there's other other things that can jog
someone's creativity and you know how do
you have those in all these writing
classes you're the teacher okay to get a
piece of paper okay I want you to look
at you know what you had for breakfast
this morning something very simple like
that but there's other more sort of
obscure sure yeah I mean I think for
just getting something started like I I
can't write at all is almost oh it's
almost a dream to me now I think because
you what happens is you get in a place
where projects are lengthy and you're in
the middle of project and so usually
you're you're fixing things or reinter
you know kind of reinterpreting things
like so you kind of already know where
you're going to go but just in terms of
like if I have a blank slate and this
fictional life where like all my
projects are finished I'm like what am I
going to do next
I do love I love proms be early early in
my writing career I had kind of one of
those books it was the writers book of
days and and it just has you know what
is the coldest day that you've ever
experienced and then you can do fiction
you can do non nonfiction the coldest
day just takes those words like little
you know there's the one where you open
a book and pick a sentence and then you
write from that I saw one the other day
as I was flipping through the short film
book I'm going to be using and it I
can't remember but it was like they had
something kind of set up and the person
has to make a decision and so and I
thought that was really nice because it
implies character and action and
motivation all in that same thing
whereas you know the coldest day could
end up just being kind of like an elegy
for snow
trees like this if once you know there's
a decision you know a lot of things so
those kinds of things I don't know if
you've ever you know I think when I was
working on my thesis I did prompts a lot
because I was on a deadline I felt like
it had to be perfect and one of my
girlfriends bought me that writer's
block book that's like a block of
prompts and it has pictures and words
and things like that so I would start
off with that but sometimes even putting
myself on a timer and just going write
something you know just just the active
and find it you know like I'd end up
writing about dancing or music or you
know anything that that sound the sound
was often very because I had like a
little egg timer and just the ticking of
it I think I do think that I that I
connect rhythmically to things and so
like water like you know sometimes
showers are just a great prompt you know
to get myself outside of myself so there
isn't I don't tend to use prompts a lot
but I do you know use music as a way to
get out of myself and into something
else you know but nothing that sounds
grand or fantastic it's whatever gets me
outside of myself is what usually is a
great prompt for me I was looking at
another talented screenwriters site and
her name is Shelley Gustafson calm and
she says in this one article there are
stories that you figure out and then
right and then there are stories that
you figure out as you write them I mean
lots
oh that's interesting I'm amazed that
you figure out and then write or stories
that you figure out as you write them I
think that's true I think that's true
both for my work as a journalist and a
screenwriter I mean I can go into an
interview believing that it's going to
go one way and it turns out to be an
entirely new thing I mean it's a little
off topic but I remember when 9/11
happened and I was supposed to have
interviewed John Schneider at that time
he was super the Superman she was the
father of Superman for the CD for
Smallville thank you and we had been
trying to get this thing together
you know we had canceled and he was out
of town and and so I contacted his
publicist and she's like no he still
wants to do it
and it was the day that George Bush was
delivering the prayer after 9/11 and I
was on the freeway and we still hadn't
heard from one of my cousins who lived
in New York and so I'm just like weeping
in the car and it's just it was just so
stressful
and so I pulled myself together I go to
his home his wife and lets me in he's
upstairs watching the prayer and so I'm
like trying to get myself composed and
he comes down and I'm you know I've got
journalism face on journalists face on
you know hello how are you and he's like
did you know anybody and all I kept
thinking of is we don't know where
Barbara is and I just broke down and so
you know what I thought was just going
to be this innocuous personality profile
about this actor turned into a really
interesting revealing story not only
about the character
he was playing but what justice and what
patriotism and and all these things
meant so you know a story that was
supposed to be this you know cute little
personality profile about this actor
turned into something deeper and richer
and you know I talked to my editor about
whether or not I should include the fact
that I wept on this man's white shirt
and you know and so it was it was one of
those things even now in kind of what
we're doing the work that we're doing we
had a certain you know focus and and an
idea about it and I think as we've gone
through the screen this screen Writing
Workshop in Switzerland and the
experiences that we've had they're just
stepping back from that screenplay for a
couple of weeks and then coming back and
just kind of reevaluating what what is
it that we're trying to say and how are
we saying it and are we really affecting
not only good story but are we really
saying something with the way that we're
going I think it can happen but I think
it definitely can happen both ways and I
was open to it as a journalist because
it was always fun it's like a discovery
you know when when you have
preconceptions of what your story is but
then it develops into something very
different I think there's something very
exciting about that and something very
very freeing about it if you allow
yourself to open yourself to that it can
be you know you can go in a direction
because I think even to a certain extent
some of the things that we've done at
least in this screenplay have moved
further from what I thought my original
idea was but it's so much better and
like I'm working on a documentary where
I thought I was going to have a
particular story that was going to go in
a particular way and time and finances
because I don't have the money to
continue to generate it once it's done I
can see it it's already a different
story because there was a particular
timeframe on that story that I thought
oh I'm gonna get it done and I'm gonna
get this and you know the personality is
going to be great and didn't turn out
that way you know and so looking at how
that story can evolve now it's going to
be a not you know the story that I was
wanting to tell was great this story
could be even greater because of not
only my experience and time but because
of new circumstances and new
developments and new undertones and
things like that so so yeah I think it
can I I definitely think working with it
with something and and having it be what
you thought it was going to be is great
but also the discovery of something new
from what you thought you had is also a
wonderful gift I think yeah from really
if I'm honest I'm always figuring it out
as as I write even if I go in thinking
that I know what it is I'm still going
to end up figuring it out as I go yeah
this is I have inside out writing and
outside in writing and the outside in
will tend to be something where there's
kind of an external story and
and so you're kind of you've got the
container a little bit and then you're
figuring out all of the ways that you're
furnishing and arranging what's in that
container and generating some new stuff
but and then when occasionally I I have
the luxury of doing kind of what I call
the inside-out where you just you have
almost nothing you have like you woke up
in the middle of the night with like an
image in your head or you know you're
just kind of just very fragmentary thing
like a grain of sand and then it's like
you're making stone narrative stone soup
you're like here's the pebble and then
you know do you know the story of stone
stones who do they go around they get
the meat and the carrots and and
everything and then it's more like it's
like found art like just pulling all of
the the things from your life your
memories and what's going on and and
you're kind of building it out from from
this little thing and it becomes
something where you really didn't have
much of an idea what it was going to be
at all and so that's that's pretty fun
and and that would again of course be an
example of figuring it out here as you
go the difference between editing
revising and just plain skimming your
work or a page that you've done for the
day
either skimming it praising it or
skimming it unfortunately trashing it
critical of it so what are the
difference between the three editing
revising and skimming or are they all
kind of the same in something skimming
is what I do when I don't know what I'm
going to do then you're kind of and
okay so editing editing revising
skimming interesting I don't know how
often I ever skim the skin would be like
a copy edit or I literally kind of just
I don't even I'm just tired and I'm like
okay I'm just going to read this through
and maybe
Oh can't remember Eric maybe it was Eric
Ross he's a screenwriter is he the one
who did Benjamin Button and what he
talks about when he writes he always
starts at the beginning and read through
up to where every day he read through up
to where he's going to start writing and
then writes from there and of course in
the reading through there's little
things you want to change so so I'll do
that
but for actual and and then there's
editing like copy editing and I make
tons of typos so I definitely do that as
well
and then I give it to other people to
edit and then I edit it again and then
there's it's still a mess but but
revision I try to approach it as a very
specific process whereby I go into it
with a plan I'm like okay this is a
scene and the scene has these building
blocks and it's weak in a certain like
there's a beginning a middle and an end
and it needs some kind of adjustment and
and so I try to look within that scene
at kind of the polarity you know like
there's a little tiny usually a little
tiny character arc within the scene
right somebody you know opens the door
for their date help you know I'm hopeful
and then they have a little conversation
and by the time they get to the car
they're feeling like this is going to be
great or by the time they get to the car
they're like this is already a disaster
and those are two different things and
so a lot of times I think the revision
process is is you've kind of looked at
the scene in terms of tracking what the
character is going to go through
throughout the entire script where does
where does the scene fit into it how is
it setting up for other things what does
it need to do so I look at it in terms
of function and in terms of those
building blocks and I so when I revise I
have a very like now it does this and I
want it to either do this better or I
wanted to do something different that's
my ideal that's my ideal revision
you don't always get that luxury
sometimes you're just like this sucks
and somehow I've got to make it seem
better and then you're just fiddling but
revision in its ideal form for me is
that editing skimming and revista
position I think to a certain extent I
agree with all of that for me when I'm
writing something I do tend to just
write out just completely and and then
go back and read what I've written
before I go to bed or before I give it
up and see if I can go a little you know
and then do the the tweaking and even to
a certain extent see how much further I
can go until I hit a wall and then the
next morning I go back and reread like I
don't I I do a lot of self editing
whether it be for small words or how can
I say this better how can it sound more
real how can it sound more authentic
because I think as a journalist I I
write differently than I speak and so
one of the challenges for me with
dialogue has been listening to how
people speak and the cadence to which
people speak and that's why going to
cafes was important to me because
getting the rhythm of a particular
speech pattern was important to me I
would listen to my friends and it
actually screenwriting made me a better
listener because I would listen to what
there was what people were saying and
how they were saying it and what
inflections they gave it so when I when
I edit it's like a mic eat am I in am i
keeping that rhythm is that Kate
still flowing so I'm looking and editing
for specific things and then with the
revision like with what Barrington was
saying you know looking at the overall
and and what can make the overall better
I guess the editing and skimming kind of
go hand in hand for me it's like I'm
doing that all at one time looking for
different things but I actually like the
process of editing and I'm working as an
editor now for Los Angeles Review of
Books and you know working on other
people's work and looking at how to make
that their work better because that was
always one of the things that I loved
about my editors is that they kept the
voice that I was looking for and in my
voice in the story they just made it
that much better and so that's what
editing for me is it's a way to make
things better not always did editors
make it better
but those that did that was where I
found you know a strength and keeping
that voice and making sure the best of
that voice came out so what I hope when
I'm editing is just honing in on those
things that really make that voice sound
authentic and I think to our credit one
of the things that people said was that
each of the characters had their own
distinct voice and so that was really
gratifying and so now it's just the
revising and making sure all that great
voice you know is in context with a
great story and a strong sensibility and
good conflict and deep meaningful you
know great deep meaningful story story
yes that'll day wait to get out of line
and it's something that you said in
there also made me think of of
kind of you know I think my mind tends
to to jump to this kind of prose editing
but I think hearing her talk about voice
one other kind of editing that that
you'll do is you'll take a pass so
you'll do a dialogue pass especially if
you if we we don't get to do as many
passes as we'd like because it seems
like we're always writing to a deadline
but but you know given the amount of
time like you'll do a dialogue pass and
then you'll do kind of a pass for
geography and a pass for like certain
characters like you'll do you'll do a
pass where you're just kind of like
tracking where one character is
emotionally like you know do they have a
logical progression of emotion between
if you know where the beginning is and
you know where the end is or is there
some place you know in the middle where
they're in a scene but they're getting
kind of lost and you can just put in a
reaction that shows that something's
changing in them you know if they're
reacting in a certain way to what's
going on so that like it's something
that you see on the screen more right so
trying to to think of me so yeah so you
do your main character pass sometimes
you'll do like a pass for secondary
characters so you'll do those kind of
different passes and I guess that would
also fall under editorial I'm going to
take something a blogger said now I know
it's different from what you're doing
with your screenplay but I read
medium.com a lot and there's a gentleman
on there named John westenberg
and he publishes a lot of his blogs and
his latest blog that would do well from
the other day was my secret to
publishing every single day I stick to
three drafts and he says I realize over
here his tips I'm sorry he said I only
ever allow myself three drafts on any
blog post this rule stops me from
chasing perfection it stops me from
second-guessing it makes me think
carefully about what I'm doing and it
stops me from rambling pointlessly so I
know three drafts for a screenplays
different but are there certain rules
where you just you say okay I have to
this because we're just kind of just we
stop when we're on deadline yes always
that point like before we have to turn
it in there's like okay and then you
just back engineer it you're like okay
here's where we're going to have to turn
it in so here's where we're going to
have to send it to my mom to spellcheck
now or somebody is dead like yeah by the
way who is looking at it um well the
deadline the deadline that we're looking
at right now is a dream ago deadline and
and that is after we finished the
Switzerland the Switzerland process they
gave us all of these notes because they
chose to chose our script because it was
awesome clearly but they also chose our
scripts because they feel like it has
the potential to be more awesome and you
know so they give you a lot to do and so
they aren't necessarily picking you
because I think you're ready and you're
complete and it's the best thing ever
they're picking it for you know for its
promise and maybe it's something that
they can kind of nurture as they go
along so you get two months after the
end of the switzerland thing to revise
you know you've taken in all of the
wisdom and you review revise july 31st
is the deadline and and if at that point
they're feeling like it's it's ready to
show producers or whatever then they'll
come out for AFM and they try to set up
a few meetings if they can for you and
and it's called meet your match and I
think I'm not sure how formal it is but
you know we'd like for it to be ready
for that because that would be a great
opportunity and if they don't feel like
it's ready at that point and you can try
for another year and turn it in but
because we're you know celebrating our
three-year anniversary I think we'd
really like to have a good revision yeah
I think by the way I said John Western
John West John westenberg and it's Jo
Ann and then westenberg calm oh yeah
well I think John John westenberg
three drafts for a blog post is just
about perfect I usually send it after
- and then I see it and have to go back
and like do another pass because I'm
appalled that I've sent it out with so
many typos but you know it's enough to
Keanu keep the voice you you know you
you do it and then you let a day pass or
whatever you can kind of go and and
start you know cut a few things out so
that you don't ramble too much and then
that sort of thing I think that's about
perfect but for I think it's hard with a
screenplay you're really somebody
there's some quote about it that you
know it's it's never done until it gets
made and then it's done when somebody
rips it out of your hands right is
basically when it's done yeah and I
think that you know even talking to
documentary filmmakers or other
filmmakers it really is in terms of the
collaborative process it's still going
on because even after we finish this
draft there will be note that we will
get from other people or producers or
director and so the process is done when
it goes to screen because there's the
editing process that I think goes on
after we've written it and we've shot it
so understanding all that you know from
from a screenwriting standpoint though
for us it does tend to be does it the
wheat have been pretty much the all
three years we've been working on it on
deadlines for something either a
competition or our producing partner has
a deadline where he would like to see
you know a certain thing done so we've
tended to write to deadlines most yeah
you don't always know you're writing the
deadline at the beginning you're like oh
we have so much time we're just writing
and then the deadline gets closer at one
there are times when I'm rant and she's
busy for times that she's ready to go
and I've got stuff and so I think we are
able to balance the different parts of
this partnership in ways that when I
have to slack off she can pick it up
when she can't
I'm on the go with it so you know it
it's you know it's like I think we have
a yin and yang about us that that seems
to work and you know Barrington has an
outside work life my work life is here
and so I can move and flow in a
different kind of way I can edit in the
morning I can edit at night I can edit
during the middle of the day she has to
be someplace from 12:00 to 5:00 and so
you know we respect and honor that
because that's how she makes our money
so she Placerville and so for me it's
easier because I don't I'm not beholding
to a particular place so but then
Barrington's got the energy of that
little bunny with the batteries I love
you know I haven't I'm pretty good like
you know one time on task I have a I
have a certain amount of persistence for
that and I think you don't really know
what's slowing you down sometimes I'm
sure it works both ways I think you know
sometimes Janice will like we'll be
working on something that maybe feels
like it's a little bit off topic or
something and I tend you know and I'm
always trying to like pare away and like
you know I have less patience for that
kind of thing because I'm like I want to
be writing and so like I'm tired of
talking about things I want to be
writing but she's like that late I need
to tell you this and this and also I
maybe think about this and I'm like it's
too much but that when you get to the
page you never know what you might need
you know and that's and and so sometimes
like things that I was impatient in the
moment about I'm like oh that little
detail is totally going to make it so
and and you don't know how long it would
have taken you to come up with that if
you hadn't you know taking the time to
do that groundwork so
yeah so it's just a time-consuming
process running screenplays a
time-consuming process
Barrington you'd mentioned wanting to
get to writing including kind of itching
to do it but I'm curious for the two of
you how much of a role does reading play
in your lives
oh my god just so really no in fact when
you were talking about the pro writing
prompt and we went off camera I was
telling Barrington you know sometimes
when I can't get in like if I'm looking
for a word just a word I start to read
you know just finding inspiration for
how words flow how a particular word
might stand out to me I like to read
before bed and because I am editing now
I'm reading more books so that I know
what my first what my writers are
writing but then I do still write
journalistically and so I just read a
wonderful book by Negin Farsad
which was really fun and that was it was
an interesting book to read because she
is a filmmaker
neguin is a filmmaker and a comic and
wrote her first book how to make white
people laugh it's very good go get it
just making a movie right now yet she
did 13 well she did 13th Street blackout
which was her last feature independent
which was here at the Las it was at the
LA Film Fest and we actually thought in
Austin and she may be working on
something else we didn't she didn't
mention anything that she was working on
so I'm gonna follow yeah so so I read I
read her book and I was sharing it with
Barrington and one of the interesting
things having now gotten to know neguin
and and hearing her comedy her voice in
that really comes out in that book I
mean like at first reading it I was just
like wow she just goes on these tangents
and she's all over the place but that's
honey game talks and so like reading the
book
at first it was hard because I was
trying to follow this like kind of fluid
train of thought but once I got into it
it was like listening to neguin and so
it was just like those are really
wonderful examples of like how you know
use dropping on other people's
conversations or reading a particular
voice a particular book that has a a
strong voice I'm also reading another
book by Monica Coleman called bipolar
faith and it's kind of a an
autobiographical in that respect and
it's very you know the voice is very
strong and so it really gives me a sense
of especially with this work voice is so
important dialogue is so important that
you know even the reading of these kinds
of works has really helped because it's
like oh that's a really distinct voice
and and although we have the voices for
our folks for our characters in this
film as I move forward with the the
other project but the the gospel project
you know it gives me a different rhythm
for you know another set of people that
you know that I can introduce so you
have reading is really important and
it's the only other thing that I get to
do that's non writing that's still fun
no it's it's hard I think there's
nothing like becoming a writer to
deprive you of reading time and getting
into the movie business to deprive you
of the time to watch anything and so
that's that something's very sad for me
I was a reader I was as a kid I was I
was a reader and you know and a kind of
an escapist reader of fiction and it's
still one of my great joys when you find
that that perfect book that really sucks
you in but I'm a binge reader which
means you know I start and if I finish
at 3:00 in the morning that's when I
finish and if I finish at 9:00 in the
morning that's when I finish and so
sometimes like a few years ago I think
before the series started I read the
first game of thrones and I was like and
now I have to put this away or I'm going
to destroy my life and lose my job so so
that's sad so the things that I'm
reading right now and I'm in the middle
of all of them are writing is rewriting
by jakub's the showrunners Bible by Neal
Landau these are great books by the way
and right at crafting short screenplays
that connect by Claudia Johnson there's
not like an escapist fiction novel among
them and that's very sad so I think like
many people I read articles that my
friends send to me on Facebook and
sometimes those are great and one of our
faculty members gets and leaves his New
Yorker in his mailbox at work and so
that's and I you know I look forward to
writing the train every day because
everything in The New Yorker is really
well-written and it's like these little
short you know so I read short fiction
and I read these kind of articles and
stuff so I think one so one of the
things that I really look forward to
when we after this deadline and and a
couple other deadlines I have coming up
I'm like I'm gonna read a book yeah you
know I'm not so funny because I think
one of the things that made me accept
the lar B job was I was like welcome to
read some books I think about waiting
for the LA review of look right right
and so yeah and so it was one of those
things where it was it gave me an
opportunity it gave me an excuse to read
on a regular basis and so you know I
realize I do have more time than I allow
myself to actually read and a lot of the
work that I'm now getting a chance to
read I might not have because they're
there now books coming to the office and
I'm like oh this sounds good and either
I will read it or I will
you know assign a reader a writer to to
go and do it but
they always get their own copies so so I
get to keep it and like it's helpful to
share so I think reading is you know for
time crunch people it feels like a
luxury and you try to find any way you
can to do it because you know you I
don't know I don't know any writers who
don't read I mean I think to become a
better writer you have to read so yeah I
don't I think that the more I get to
read the better the better I am well do
you feel that you can become more
connected through reading or watching
films because I think David Foster
Wallace said something about there's no
better way than to like get in a reader
skin than reading and he talked about
being lonely for something that he
didn't even know what existed and what
he was lonely for what he said through
reading he was able to sometimes let
that go
some people connect with it through
books in some through film which is it
for the two of you I think is it it is
if we mean connecting in maybe the way
that David saw like those say I don't
know whose quote it is we read to know
we are not alone for me that I think is
still reading or at least that was what
it was first in my life and so I
associated it with that more it be
reading and then films and and kind of
films instead of TV even though I really
love TV I think some something about the
the closure or the way they come to an
end
like you kind of come out feeling a
little more connected where I like a
little more sated in terms of your
connection whereas TV is a little more
open-ended and and you kind of walk away
even if it was really good there's like
this kind of dissatisfaction that you
feel that you're never quite full
Heol which i think is an interesting and
interesting thing but I mean I think I
think I'm a words first person that's
good full long yeah I think for me it
would be reading even though I grew up
as a TV baby you know I watched TV more
than I read and as I got older I got it
I got into books with what would be
considered late like I didn't you know I
wasn't this voracious reader until I got
into college
and I think it was because I wanted to
know more about the world and what I was
being presented and so and as a writer
the words are so important to me just
the physical were you know the flow of
the word the sound of the word what the
word means I grew up on television and
you know in the summer time we were
outdoors you know we were really active
kids so I didn't spend as much time
reading until college and I think that
was when I was searching for things
outside of the world that I lived in and
other kinds of storytelling and and
things that were that were more
meaningful to me I got into I really got
heavily into black literature you know
Zora Neale Hurston and like my mother
was a huge fan of poetry so I started
you know seeking out poets that she you
know loved and would recite sometimes
and so I think through through words and
having chosen a career that was
dependent on words reading became really
important to me and I even had an editor
that said you know you you know reading
is important to your writing it helps
strengthen your writing and so I use
that as a way to help build my vocab my
writing vocabulary and and to extend
myself further you know I just feel like
it's it's something that you know in
this in my later years I've taken a
little for granted but even taking the
labor
the books job that was one of the things
that was really intriguing to me it was
like I get a chance to read again and I
get a chance to read again for work and
and so it puts a different onus on it
certainly but but it has opened me up to
authors and and writers and and styles
of books that maybe I might not have
read otherwise you can say younger so
when you were let's say you know five
years old or or or older did you both
know you wanted to be writers
professionally I maybe that's no
absolutely not to young of a couple now
when I didn't know that I wanted to
become a writer until I went to college
I was studying fashion merchandising at
la tre Tech and I hated my marketing
classes hated the accounting classes and
I took what I thought was going to be an
easy a in fashion writing I studied with
Glenn Jones who was the fashion editor
of the then herald-examiner she was
another she was the first black woman
besides be be more Campbell that I knew
wrote that made a living as a writer be
be more Campbell was an author and she
went to my church and I didn't
understand writing as a career I didn't
know people got paid that some people
don't get paid at all of you anymore but
but when saw something in the work that
I did and she suggested I get an
internship and helps me get an
internship at Women's Wear Daily
I'm not about doing anything else as a
career since there was something very
you know they talk about the power of
the pen and I got a chance to experience
that and what that meant to me how
affecting my work was and the results of
it it was you know like my parents come
from very blue-collar
my mother has a bachelor's degree my
father has an associate's degree but
they're both blue cop they were both
blue-collar worker blue-collar workers
and so you know when I came home one day
and told my parents I am going to become
a journalist my dad was like what is
that and how much does that pay and you
know so that was kind of the the
mentality that I grew up with it was
that you had to have a job that paid and
it had to have like benefits and all
those kinds of things but what I found
was writing was that it it gave me a
voice in the world and it gave me an
opportunity to say something and it also
gave me an opportunity to see things in
ways that I wouldn't ordinarily see like
I could go behind the scenes of stuff
and tell everybody what I saw and so I
think for me writing just writing I came
to writing and and it was something that
I didn't even know I had a strengthen
and so I began to develop and hone that
craft but it wasn't something that I set
out to do but now you know like as the
world is changing and everything is now
becoming content you know it's it's
about me finding a way to do the thing
that I love as passionately as I did
when I first started because I don't
like it being called content it's still
writing to me you know something it
means something to me to be a writer
like when blogging came out I was like
no I am a journalist you know I was very
proud of that I was very proud of
calling myself a writer I'm very very
conscientious and proud of being an
artist
someone who's transitioned into
something that feels very artistic and
so like content doesn't sound like
anything to me and so content sounds
like stuff you don't really need to pay
for
Brandon Brandon - right so I think that
you know as as I you know as I've come
along you know holding on to that
writing that that thing that says I'm a
writer is what really still because
that's what that's what drew me in was
the writing you know and so they're
always you know calls that you know I
should do you know I should probably be
making more and doing more but if it
doesn't have anything to do with writing
I don't really care you know so granted
for you do you remember the first time
you realized I want to be right yeah and
and it was not a quick was not a quick
realization I think I always you look
fat in hindsight you're like oh I've
always wanted to be a writer but in in
truth I was I was a huge reader as it
was as a kid
yes it was also Indiana yes it was
summer my mom would tell us to go
outside and read but then she would find
me hiding behind the curtains in the
air-conditioning like reading my book or
if I had to go outside I would like
there was this ditch under the highway
overpass where I'd be with my you know
with my book but it never occurred to me
that that I could that I would be a
person who would craft something and
like figure out what these people would
do and then what they would do next and
what they would do next like that seemed
I think super pie-in-the-sky to me like
it it didn't occur to me that that that
was something that I could do I was a
theater major in college and I thought I
was going to direct and a lot of and I'd
look back now and I'm like Oh a lot of
the scenes that I directed that were
very successful were scenes I wrote so I
could direct them but of course it was
that combination that made them
successful and and my jobs out of
college I had a pretty but by that point
I had a pretty
stage management background and I
parlayed that into being a production
coordinator for videos and industrials
and commercials in Chicago and then when
I made the jump and came to LA the same
kind of thing I did the logistics for
production I think I always thought own
someday I'm going to be a director and
someday somebody's going to let me be a
director but I didn't have any sense of
what that like I just thought that you
got on a set and you worked really hard
and you you know organized things and
made the phone calls and you know I was
but there's there's a ladder for that
there's a ladder for helping other
people be creative that you you know you
can go from production this is a
production coordinator to associate
producer to producer and that's that's
something that I did and it was until I
got married and I moved to the middle of
Australia with my husband and while I oh
but I should say that I'm gonna
backtrack a little bit that as a kid I
had you know a bunch of spiral ring
notebooks full of like just writing so I
was a journal or and in kind of all
through my life I've always been
somebody who instinct like I had right
so so there was always that Drive but I
just I didn't I mean I kind of look back
and I'm amazed I'm like how did I not
make this connection um so I moved to
Australia with my husband he was he was
an aerospace engineer at the time and so
it's like we lived in the desert and
like kind of in the middle of Australia
and there's like these satellite
monitoring stations in the middle of the
desert and I'm like what am I going to
do with myself and so then I started
taking some art classes which was great
and I loved it and I have a little bit
of background in that arena as well and
and then I was diagnosed with cancer in
2003 and in the wake of that it's all a
happy story everything's good now but I
am one of those people who kind of
didn't
dooba chemotherapy I like medicated and
went to cancer camp and juice carrots
and so at that point I was like well I
don't think I should be spending you
know like eight hours in the studio with
like all the solvents and the you know
the stuff like for screen printing which
was kind of the main thing that I did
and so at that point I I was kind of
like it was it was just kind of like a
weird time I was kind of physically
recovering still and and you know I had
this going on it's like I'm going to
take a writing class that Gotham Writers
Workshop that online there associated
with zoetrope and I ended up doing two
or three classes through them and they
were great I highly recommend them so
that was kind of my first official write
I think I think I tested out of English
in in college you know how you you do so
I don't even think I took an English
class in my undergraduate career in
college and I kind of look back on like
what was I thinking all I loved to do
was read I didn't even take a literature
class but so I wrote you know so there I
wrote some stories and then one day my
husband's aerospace engineer came home
and he said there's this guy at work
who's quitting to go to film school he
sucks
he's terrible at everything he's like if
anybody should go to film school I
should go to film school and then this
kind of like over the course of a couple
of days you know he really did love
movies and he was somebody who would
watch them over and over again he's like
I should go to film school and then it'd
be kind of became this thing where I'm
like well I've always I always kind of
thought oh I'm going to go to grad
school someday and I'm like look you're
going to school I'm going to school and
I'm like what what can I go to school in
like because there's no grad school for
production coordinators and I and
theater didn't seem quite right
after because I'd been working with film
and video all this time I was like well
I wrote these stories for the Gotham
Writers Workshop saying I'm like I'm
going to get an MFA in writing and then
it seemed like totally I was like yeah
that's what I should do and so I sent my
stories off and I we both got into the
program that Florida he got into the
film program and I got into the English
program at Florida State and they had a
good assistantship program like a
teaching you know you can get a TA ship
and so we're like okay that that seems
good and that was so it was a little bit
down the road for me and I played I had
to play a lot of catch-up
because it was an MFA program that was
combined with a ph.d program so like the
very first writing workshop I took was
with a PhD candidate who had been
through the Iowa Writers Workshop for
his MFA and the first thing you have to
do to get into the Iowa Writers Workshop
is I think they give you this list of
100 books you need to have read before
you even start the program and you know
so I was under ed and undertrained and
I've kind of made up for that since then
I've done a lot of I went from that
program and when we moved out to LA then
I use that to get into the screenwriting
program at USC and then I just kind of
as per like my day job allowed me to
pick up some extra classes and Deb how
we did a multi-genre writing thing at
USC as well but anyway so it took me
forever to figure out the answer to that
question
that's how the two of you met yeah
that's how we met I we weren't there at
the same weren't there at the same time
along weena alumna high weight will RIT
alumni alumni alumni alumni Laurel yeah
for female the whole email is a female
Boras alumni no longer but yes we met at
a mixer of alums and part of the
afternoon gathering we were supposed to
tell a little bit about ourselves what
we were looking to do and what we could
help someone else in the group do and I
had just
started I had just finished like six
weeks of exhaustive research into
Persian culture for the screenplay
adaptation of the book and barrington or
even I think the instructor mentioned
that Barrington could help anybody with
a screenplay and so I wasn't you know
all I what it was an outline so I
thought oh okay so I made a beeline to
her and gave her a copy of the book and
so that was kind of how we we started
swirling this world it was swirling yeah
so so but it was interesting when
Barrington was talking about her
journaling as it as a young person I did
do a lot of that when I was growing up
and you know because I was such an avid
TV watcher I would find myself
envisioning my self or people that looks
like me into my favorite TV shows and so
my brother and I would sometimes like
write little like guest starring roles
for ourselves in life this would be how
we would see this episode going you guys
wrote fan fiction we did but we didn't
know and like when weren't existed yeah
and when you were saying that I was like
you know the fact that I decided to do a
writing course in college for an easy a
was because that was the thing that I
did for fun but I never imagined doing
it as a profession like I didn't think
that was something you did but I do know
like I would write stories about the
kids at church like I have this I still
have it like my brother asked me about
it like years ago he's like you really
should publish that and it was called
all God's children it was like my soap
opera version of all the kids Church but
it was like and it was like all cuz
there were all it was hormones were
teenagers it was all these casts of
crazy kids from different walks of life
you know we had kids from Englewood and
Kings Fairfax High and you know all the
school where I wrote
rivalries and things like that and I was
the nerdy kid that all the cool kids
talk to and so I know all their secrets
and then of course I tell my brother all
of them could no bomb and he was late
and so we were I wrote a little little
play thing and I still have it in my
stuff it's like a one thing that I kept
because it's just hysterical and and I
actually won like a competition in high
school for writing and I found that
while I was cleaning up recently
so yeah it's funny I never really
thought about it but I think I've been
writing something in some kind of way my
my whole life you both appear determined
to have your script lovers in their
right mind named your pocket okay made
into a movie when did you go from the
mindset of writers to producers like
what what did you feel that at some
point you could pitch it and someone
else would make it and then you started
to realize okay if this is going to get
made well it was kind of a interesting
when we first developed the outline for
the project
it did have a production it was it was a
fourth production that her book was
under option yes I was under right so
they were open to writers to they'd sent
the book out apparently to a few writers
to see if they might have a take on it
and I'm not sure that they got a great
response but Janice had said can I try
and they said sure and I think that that
what this particular company was
probably looking for was a little bit of
you know another action so actually with
like multiracial couples because if
you've read the book it's kind of a
how-to guide on is like so what to
Expect When You're Expecting I had
generally run out the Steve Harvey book
had just come out I can't I have nothing
yeah I can't remember it was a dating
book that was made a women in Mars no no
no why can't I think about it because
Anika was in this
second one but it made two films and and
so I think they were looking for
something more ensemble and might be a
little broader and a little bit more
broader and a lot more comedic I am I
tend to be someone who gravitates
towards independent films I'm a huge fan
of drama and so my idea was more along
the lines even though this was a little
comedic but what you know like my Big
Fat Greek Wedding where it was one
couple that was dealing with the the
integrate intercultural dynamic and you
know guess who's coming to dinner was
also a bit you know like when I was
thinking of of films in this genre it
always dealt with one person you know
one couple and their relationship with
their family so they thought it was a
really cool idea but they didn't feel
like they could sell it and in the
interim
novena gabon and I had been dating and
he was an actor he was on homeland and
played Abu Nazir for two seasons and he
said well I want to see it because
you've been talking to me about this
project and you know and you know like
his big thing was a my research for this
or what it wasn't what's not really
going on between us and so so he
barrington and I want the production
company he said well you know thanks but
no thanks I shed a few tears and then he
said well I want to see what you've done
what you guys have done and we met at a
Cooper cafe in Beverly Hills I will
never forget this and we were all ready
to kind of just like well you know we'll
hear you out but we're kind of done
because we didn't have the protection of
a production company behind us and we
left there I remember us walking to our
cars because he had come and in left and
we left after him and we were like wait
did he just talk us into writing this
screenplay and producing it ourselves
because he really felt like there was
thing there he's like we could do this
movie this is you know we can produce it
ourselves and we were just like wait did
we just agree to do this so we became de
facto producers because we wanted to see
this project done so yeah yes and and I
don't think that we've given up yet on
the idea that somebody might come in and
sweep us off our feet although it's
harder and you get quote you you I think
especially early in the writing process
you're like oh maybe you won't just have
the script and somebody's going to buy
it they're going to make it and like we
can go on with our lives
but you get attached to something and
then you start to have more ideas how
you might like to have it made or you
know how you you kind of want to you you
feel more ownership over it and at this
point it would have it would have to be
the right I think it would have to be
the right offer or the right deal
fortunately again as my represent as my
representation and and others nobody
seems to be jumping on the opportunity
to do it instead of us so we're people
problem hopefully we don't we probably
won't have to make that choice not to
bring on a real a real I yeah producer
you know more experienced producer who
knows people with money
yeah well chance aside from you loving
drama and independent film why tackle
this subject dramatically instead of
using humor which seems to be the way
that people find certain things that
scare because a general huge drama queen
that's what one is it was humor um
because I think you can say so I mean I
don't think that this is completely you
know there's humor really weird climb
back and forth on whether to call it a
dramedy or a rated quirky Indies kind of
fall in that tonally in that I don't
know uncanny valley of visit a comedy is
it a drama and I mean we certainly have
comedic this means I mean meeting
elements it should not bra
it's not a yeah it's not a broad comedy
and I think that it to me
you know it's an independent film in
that it lives in that same kind of
sensibility where you can have a film
feel like your life my life is not
completely dramatic it's not completely
humorous it just is my life and it
encompasses all of those things and so
this film encompasses that you know it
has some drama it has some comedy it has
some romance it has some sex you know
you know it has some life and so I think
that for me it's important it's
important for me for this film to look
like it's lived like it's a project that
lives in in this time in this space it's
really important for me that the cast
looks like the people we're writing
about it's important for me for them to
sound like the people that were writing
about and so whether that be you know a
lot of the script has Persian dialogue
in it a lot of this group has because
Persian Americans do speak their own
language when they're with themselves
that's real to me and that became very
even in conversation they can flow from
Persian to English and that's a part of
the script because and and and so a lot
of my eavesdropping and listening and
having friends who are Persian and
having a Persian producer and people
involved with this project who speak to
the sensibilities that we're trying to
affect it gives the film its life and so
that you know that's that's that's what
that's what connects me to independent
film because these are stories that that
aren't
hi Lee you know finance so you're
getting to the core you know where you
know we finally found that like we've
got to cut some scenes because we can't
afford it like go to all these different
sets and so you get to the core of it
you get to the heart of it and not that
the the big-budget films aren't great
but there's something connective to me
about that kind of stripping down of all
the stuffs and the glamour and the
cutesy and the whatever and you get to
the core of the story that's that's kind
of what I wanted to do is just tell it's
a good story it's it's it's drama comedy
it's a good story and I think that's
what what's resonating was the people
that read it